foi a eu amo cadeias
eu acho que isso é uma forma maravilhosa
conta histórias e são uma forma de arte
que nunca sabe o médico mérito que
merecia
então eu aqui hoje vou tentar fazer é
mostrar os seus valores dos quadrinhos e
convencer vocês atentarem primeiro quero
tirar a o preconceito que quase não são
só os super heróis da marvel dc
existem milhões e milhões de outros
tipos de quadrinhos por exemplo
persépolis a história real de uma garota
no irã durante a evolução humana e como
ela convive com isso ou o reembolso a
história fictícia ambiente de
consciências fábulas esse tipo de moraes
em nova york
hoje em dia ou de histórias que são os
heróis que nós conhecemos mas ruiz
diferente como o superman no inter foi o
martelo que conta a história de um super
homem comunista han
os rodeios ultimamente tem recebido mais
valor mas não senti e tudo começou com
esse livro um contato com deus escrito
por will age wire é um dos maiores
quadrilhas da história e ele queria que
seus órgãos fossem levados a sério então
ele começou a usar o termo graphic novel
para tentar fazer com que ganhasse mais
respeito em quadrinhos a fazer um apoio
muito bem
o movimento aqui pra ver antes
quadrinhos fazer movimentos rápidos
muito bem dá pra ver todo o a velocidade
de todos a todos os movimentos mas
também fazem movimentos violentos muito
bem
além do socorro com muitos detalhes e é
muito legal que consegue sentir um
movimento de cada cena e se mexendo é
legal
ele falou também que seriados e filmes
usam uma coisa meio parecida com a de
inscrição o storyboard pra tentar
demonstrar as suas como as cenas têm que
ser tomadas
escolhemos são tão bonzinhos que os
quadrinhos baseados em filmes usam seus
próprios quadrinhos como storyboard como
em 300 algumas cenas são tiradas
diretamente do filme do padrinho em
watchmen maioria do filme tirado de um
grande padrinho e e insiste que todas as
cenas de toda a história do filme
literalmente do filme do quadrinho tudo
exatamente igual e os quadrinhos são
parecidos com as séries porque cada país
natal pelo menos ao próximo episódio e
cada arco parece uma temporada em uma
experiência muito parecida
uma rã mas em comparação com séries e
filmes
os quadros são coisas que os que eles
não têm ou na verdade os filmes e séries
tem uma coisa que eles não têm pressão
melhores
os atores em quadrinhos não tem como um
ator ruim estragar um personagem que
gosta
porém pela intervenção é tua e isso faz
com que possa ler um quadrinho até o
próprio ritmo no teu próprio pode olhar
para um quadro um dos quadrinhos e fica
horas examinando cada detalhe ou outro
pode ler rápido todo ritmo isso é muito
legal
alguns filmes que são baseados em
quadrinhos são 15 mil homens de preto
verde não sei 300 e algumas das séries
são angélica jones led usaf walking dead
mas ele parece que estou dizendo que
quadrinhos são livros com as artes
movimento nas estradas mas falta uma
coisa arte a arte mais forte mais
importantes podem não são incríveis em
fazer arte por exemplo em cenas
grandiosas como essa ou a próxima ou com
um no próprio quadrinho quando se b
as histórias são contadas conseguem com
um conta de maneira bonita e juntando as
partes do os seus 18 pedras no design ou
mostrando o título da história dentro do
design de quadrinho os políticos que
pelo o irã ele todos os títulos são
inscritos dentro do design das páginas e
fazem sentido é o prédio se inscrever no
spirit o uac folhas vamos querer o
spirit é muito legal design de tudo
então espero que eu tenha mostrado o
quanto vocês gostem que você tem uma
chance com essa forma de arte
obrigado
[Aplausos]